sir it is always a pleasure to sit
across from you thank you
what do I need to do after seeing the
movie what do I need to do to have you
acting and directing more talk to my
wife uh you know it's very consuming to
do these two things together I used to
wonder like like one of my mentors and
idols was Melosh foreman who directed
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest and
Amadeus and I did Larry Flynt the People
vs Larry Flynt with him and I used to
sort of look at me like I could like
this is one of the most award-winning
directors ever in the history of the
business why is he take so long between
his projects and now I know I know
because he needed to sleep for four
years when he was done I've spoken to a
number of filmmakers and what a lot of
people in the general public might not
realize is it can take two three years
of your life and it's this is all you
can do yeah I this just what do we into
a fall 2019 so yeah this has been - the
two solid years no not even it's it's
yeah it's it's over two solid years that
I've been working on it since we started
actually prepping it but for five years
before that I I had my script and I was
trying to get this cast together and get
it together I was doing some other
things then but it takes up a lot of
space - it takes up a lot of space to do
something big and ambitious you know
well no matter what happens after this
interview I just need you acting more
and because I just I'm a big fan thank
you
one of the things I want to talk about
tonight I want to commend Warner
Brothers for making the movie with you
because these movies are really tough to
get made nowadays it's true but you know
what's interesting is I I don't I have a
affection in a romance for sort of the
history of Hollywood in some ways in and
I do I am happy with this particular
film I get very happy when that Warner
Brothers logo spins up because they
Warner Brothers made LA Confidential
they made like Clint Eastwood's you know
movies they made our go with Ben Affleck
they there is an actual tradition at
that studio of of like of supporting
grown up muscular visions of actor
director you know it really is a
tradition there and I I feel like those
were some of the films that inspired
this film I wanted to make one of those
kinds of films like a like my you know
my memory of LA Confidential was I
couldn't tell you the plot of that movie
today but but about two minutes into it
my brain went oh man I am really happy
to be through the glass and into this
because it felt right just like the
music was great the actors were were
grounded and gutsy and serious and
whatever was going on I didn't know what
the hell was going on and I didn't care
because you're you're lost you're
hypnotized and I think that that's that
hypnosis that sense of having been
carried into a world and where there are
characters the that have a hold on you
and you don't care where they take you
that's that's what I love about those
films and so I think everybody loves
about those films it's it's the romance
of movies it's what it's the being taken
away into something other than our
pedestrian kind of daily experience here
and that's what I wanted to do and you
did it I already have to go and that's
it I have a million other questions sir
it's a pleasure again you thank you so
much pleasure